The Reagan coalition was based on an
alliance between,
on the one hand,
small government,
you know,
pro big business conservatives on the
one hand and the kind of cultural
resentments,
especially among white working class
Americans on the other,
they held those together.
It was a very reliable way for the
Republican Party to retain national
power.
I think that's common glued.
It's come unglued for a variety of
reasons.
2008 being one of them and the
Republicans had not much to offer their
working class,
you know,
followers except what more tax cuts,
cut social security.
I mean Donald Trump understood that.
That was one of the reasons that he was
able to come in and take the part tech,
the nomination for himself.
He understood the class aspects of all
of this in a way that the republican
establishment just did not,
and they were coming forward with the
all the old bromides.
Right.
And he came along and said,
no,
no.
Yeah,
the tax issues,
but we can even compromise the tax
stuff.
Minimum wage.
Maybe not such a bad idea,
but free trade,
free trade,
free trade.
I'm going to be the man who can make the
deals now that is not the typical
republican establishment or even the
typical republican line.
Um,
so he was able to look,
he was able to move to the left,
if you will.
So he's on the left of the Republican
Party.
He's more like Bernie Sanders in many
ways on some issues than he is like the
Republican Party.
At the same time,
he's doing all the,
you know,
the xenophobia,
the racism,
all of that.
So where is the,
the center to all of that?
I don't know,
which is really what makes him,
I think,
and this is where the Clinton people
have to be very concerned.
It makes them a very unpredictable
candidate.
It makes it very difficult to gauge.
You kind of knew what you were getting
with.
Certainly if Jeb Bush had gotten the
nomination or if Ted Cruz had gotten the
nomination to very different people,
you kind of knew what,
what,
what was there with trump who cheat,
who changed position that he held at
nine o'clock in the morning with great,
you know,
I'm great fervor.
You can change it all by four o'clock in
the afternoon.
I mean,
this makes it,
we're not dealing in a fact based
universe here.
We're dealing in reality television.
It's something that we,
that no political consultant I think is
quite figured out.
If he becomes president,
will he be able to do everything that he
says he's going to do?
No,
we do have still have a constitution.
If you suspends the Constitution,
um,
as you might imagine and some,
some,
some fantasy,
right?
We were under great attack or something
and he suspends the Constitution.
Well then we have a crisis that we've
never faced as a country before except
possibly in the case of obsession in
1860,
61,
um,
where,
you know,
that was a,
that was a constitutional crisis that
ended up with 750,000 military dead.
Um,
um,
I don't want to go through that again.
Can trump do whatever he wants as
president?
Can he become a dictator only by
suspending the constitution of the
United States under the constitution
mean that I'd say there are plenty of
subject,
plenty of checks and balances on him.
Not as much as you might like that
within the military.
You know,
he is commander in chief.
So,
uh,
it,
it would be a crisis presidency.
Yeah.
Every time you one of these movements
and they've been,
again,
they've occurred before in American
history.
There's always an argument that somehow
somebody has taken America away from
Americans and we're going to try to
bring it back,
take it back from them and restore what
was,
um,
that happened with the federalists in
1800 of that,
the natural unnatural as immigrants.
It happened in the 1850s with Irish
immigrants and you know,
Catholic immigrants and German Catholic
and Irish and German Catholic
immigrants.
And it's happening now.
Um,
something terrible has been taken away
and they're trying to bring it back.
It's appealing to people's fears.
They're appealing,
appealing to people's sense of,
um,
uh,
appealing to people's sense that they
are no longer,
they no longer count,
um,
these appealing to people's sense of
their,
their resentments and grievances.
But we've seen that before as well.
I mean,
this isn't,
there's nothing new about any of this.
Interestingly,
it's usually a sign or it's been a sign
of a political party that's about the
cracked up.
Um,
and that certainly happened in 1800.
It happened in the 1850s,
in 1920s and thirties.
The,
uh,
the old guard and the Republican Party
that brought back the economics that led
to the Great Depression,
they too,
are being bought up by a resurgence of
nativism,
which led to a law in 1924 that grossly
destroy restricted immigration from
abroad.
In all three cases,
the parties either collect entirely or
they were marginalized.
The Republicans didn't elect a president
from Franklin Delano Roosevelt coming in
in 1932 until 30 years later.
And the,
the,
um,
the president,
they elected in 1952,
Dwight Eisenhower basically ratified a
new deal consensus.
So,
so this,
this great,
I'm making America great again.
Usually means that a party's about to
get,
get under,
you know,
fall under great pressure.
Um,
it's going to,
if not collapsing target,
at least it's going to disintegrate or
be pushed to the margins.